hi I'm Greg I'm John I'm Andrew John is
John Andrew is movie source channel and
Twitter a or 7-eleven C corporations are
people
guys I showed Andrew a video called a
superhero Bowl they're called tune
sandwiches segments from the channel
aren't spear entertainment okay and
they're they're totally cool we do
reaction to them that's awesome
and they have a new video out got many
requests first person with Irish Red
Devil please react Irish Red Devil cool
name for you and coming to brag all the
crotch colatina
e looks watches do it John did not see
superhero bull no idea what we're
getting into
I'm excited I'm sure that's true you
know you gonna pay for that right not
our guy I don't know what came over me
not against one side look I just
couldn't stop not that's bit me strength
well I said you want to be run I intend
to get maggot what else elves an x-men
thing maybe a quarter of it hasn't done
remember the other three quarters is on
surrender is ready now Bangu forgive at
the first step is admitting you have a
problem what problem
[Music]
what girl come on stand next to you
could turn huggin I think you're my step
in poop no no
[Music]
alright only two calls per hand so you
can only cook for cab add that it's on
dr. vu Gurley
we can drop him nope nope no Lee yes
not tonight I resent that comparison I
identify not motorcycle I'm not whatever
it is easygoing I think you my dad
these were my first good those could
have done from any blog
hey no you look on camera I thought he
won I was damaged shouldn't you still
look like you school treat a famine yeah
so you like the reverse Dorian Gray oh
right now I have to make another nine
movies like the watch someone will come
ha ha someone has come along right well
I don't and his name local uh craggy
more bloody world
[Music]
I'm sure you wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for me I knew you and my dad not
that the Sentinel I went back is done
and stop the Sentinels for destroying in
kind oh here we go again the Sentinels
don't indulge in Fantasy 6 murder a
whole bunch Maggie not being active it
sure I'd like to buy your vision sir
please step out of the vehicle
aah what are you picking on me for this
is Mutis discrimination you're a music
ladies firm have you been drinking to
dance are just a couple of white ones
well so do you recognize me on the
bloody Wolverine on it sir you appear to
be drunk and let's say driving while
intoxicated carries a minimum of three
offers on coupon almost elaborate a kid
I'll show you kids what does that call
me for get the other die you shredded it
from the top and then you use the
shrimp's to rob joint all that's a lie
well I'll prove it okay I'm a daddy and
run it all through me
Sarris drop the concealed weapon
considerate anyway I'd imagine guarded
barn cause we don't go up kid sorry
buddy boy
I have no idea what he's talking about
she's lying again she's got two thirds
as much foam core as I am sir interlace
your bone across behind your head and
drop to your knees
have you heard of the it's been open
x-man whoa an excess man but still the
x-men is I not heard of the x-men that's
what that Cyclops guy right he's amazing
[Music]
Wow
now that was the circle Wolverine see
that no one was here to see it sounds
like Wolverine circa Rick or Archer
something like that yeah like I really
like how to capitalize on the drunk
aspect of Wolverine in this it is real
chewy yeah I don't know but letting he
just really drew up the entire time hey
I love that even this shot of the close
liked a few memorable shop in the
trailer like when a closer shot faces
eyes open with a head like a bunch of
beer cans as I understand it was really
[ __ ] I always loved do they establish
this heat for Cyclops and yeah I mean
that he did something like Cyclops could
have done that or a great call vector
yeah this is really funny I mean this
almost reminded me of like a more
subdued animated Aldo Jones sketches a
lot of like how bad is your holiday yeah
yeah definitely
but they definitely do have their own
style to it for sure for sure yeah no
this is cool is the first time I've ever
seen this and I thought this was really
fun because it's more than just how it
should have ended how they should have
done something it's always listed almost
like a parrot yeah a parody more
specifically it just seems it's in the
vein of like how it should have ended
also do their kind of exploring more
like funnier sides of what they could be
thinking in the certain team yeah I like
seeing like different sizes we get some
more serious take when you see the film
and then you get some more like comedic
parody cider and just I love I love
seeing stuff like this when it's
cleverly and well done yeah hello would
you like flips in the air and she looks
like bored I'd love those like weird
little physics breaker to the attentions
to detail a lot of the shots too were
like really reminded me
boom I really love like how they just
made him a straight-up Aussie alcoholic
yeah yeah
no never an accent and no American
accent is one daughter so you gotta do
the voice of Patrick Stewart Center
really good yeah he's done a great shout
for a second half the question I think
of a just took the audio from the trail
yeah and the dinner-table thing what are
you talking about a Maggie - like oh
here we go yeah just how crazy drunk I
love it once oh I love the way they're
animated conceptually Wolverine a Logan
Alaura have these gigantic eyes and they
make it I don't know I've always been
shown characters a huge eyes much longer
just one more thing that would have been
it all so hysterical whenever they
mentioned the Cyclops thing like just a
funny little callback because he kind of
flipped up Cyclops in the first x-men
film yeah with one of his claws and what
is that it's like when someone said leg
up see we just done that with anybody
but I thought it was so cool in that
personally like ah yeah I knee called
him a dick or whatever yeah as I said
and the real I'm it's me prove it your
dick okay hey I love this spoof scenes
as some things I thought it would cross
my mind briefly though you're like not
gonna happen in the movie oh you know
they drive around in these like one part
they're driving in a truck it's
completely [ __ ] up Logan drives a
couple of cars in this movie that are
totally [ __ ]
oh yeah I think never gets pulled over
on his road trip and it's Martin Sammy
but that moment of the cop pulled him
over that was really funny well yeah
they make fun of stuff that might not
look just logistically or logically work
in a film but like I'm just exposing and
having more fun with it but when you're
having a great time in a film you just
say whatever like you let it go but it's
cool when they expose and make fun of
stuff like that it's like that's
probably going to happen but it's more
fun to explore it on these videos what
it's bringing it down to those like
regular likes might you sure yeah yeah
she's playing and they're swooping the
trailer moments because I think it could
have even stoop like Laura driving the
car for long periods on time and not
once getting pulled over
oh yeah I prefer girl driving the cooker
yeah
here animations I like that's actually a
very clever way I'm sure of saving some
time and making some of them looks
really good you know I don't know
exactly how they do it but I think that
is a bullet of practical in a very cool
test I'm not going to live when they
were doing the beer thing in the in the
car I thought they were going to parody
a little Dumb and Dumber we're like they
eat peas into this thing and maybe make
how long I get or something I don't know
that's what it's kind of like making but
I thought was pretty funny how she did
we did that rather we were running late
to Logan and I said we don't have time
he's about it I thought I told you not
to tell anyone about that I know we're
on camera so me oh never mind
Cameron oh wow forget embarrassing
stories if it's on camera you know I
don't like private conversation like in
a lie it was tangy I did have a lot of
orange juice that makes a lot of time I
know you lack vitamin C thanks man so I
thought my like halftime at a soccer
game Thank You Man
I appreciate it you can subscribe to the
real rejects John has reason to Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram he manages social
of media's on the real rejecting Blum
house Andrews
egg or 7-eleven on Twitter and Instagram
hey he also has a movie channel called
the movie source janitor machine we got
to go there watch it and shout out the
arts fear entertainment an awesome shot
our sphere is damnit the really kind
guys had a few e-mails back and forth
well very very kinda deserve way more
subs than what they currently have and
they are very clever to channel their
vertically yeah art spear
oh I'm going to make a good dad I